[Musique]
c'était la météo avec sirius fabricant
de chauffe eau solaires à la réunion
merci de nous rejoindre ce début de
semaine nous sommes lundi et c'est le
rendez vous politique avec voghell
dantec bonjour bonjour je suis bonjour à
tous l lundi politique
gaël le dantec à partir d'aujourd'hui
lundi et 15 avril nous entrons dans une
nouvelle phase de la campagne pour les
élections européennes les médias
audiovisuels sont tenus de respecter une
équité dans le temps de parole donnée
aux différents candidats
pour l'instant les listes définitives ne
sont pas encore connues elles seront
déposées d'ici début mai la liste
renaissance de l'appliquant marché ses
alliés est au complet sa tête de vie
s'appelle l'oiseau est actuellement en
visite à la réunion enelistes en
revanche qui a un peu du mal à se
définir c'est celle de places publiques
et du parti socialiste
notre invité nous on vient on l'espère
un peu plus nous parlerons avec lui de
rock leur en but 10 idées gilet jaune du
grand débat ou encore la situation du
parti socialiste philippe maillet
premier secrétaire fédéral du ps
conseiller municipal à saint denis
candidats aux élections européennes et
la vitesse de lundi politique sur la
première jusqu'à 13h vos questions par 7
12 heures 45 au 02 62 90 de ville
philippe maillet bonjour bonjour mme
seul dantec merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans l'actualité il ya cette
allocution des macros attendus ce soir
20h france et sera diffusé sur la
première 1 2 heure en direct
le président doit faire des annonces
suite à la restitution du grand débat
qu'est ce que vous en attendez vous j'ai
envie de dire d'abord qui serais tu en
as qu'il serait temps que le président
de la république tire les enseignements
de cette crise sociale inédite
il n'est pas responsable de tout bien
sûr mais il a contribué quand même à
l'émergence de ce qu'on appelle le
mouvement des gilet jaune qui correspond
à une colère profonde injustice fiscale
des salariés qui considère
qu'aujourd'hui aller travailler pour pas
grand chose
c'est quelque chose de terrible qui
parfois ne vont peut-être pas le coup
donc il ya toute une série de malaises
de mécontentement qui s'est raté
oui depuis maintenant le mois de
novembre dans la société française c'est
ce qui peut faire des avances ce soir
qui vont jeu
je ne sais pas s'il va faire les avants
ce soir parce que j'ai cru comprendre
que ce serait en deux temps ce soir une
intervention solennelle et des annonces
qui sont attendues pour mercredi
mercredi
rencontre avec la presse et puis
s'imposer ce qui est important c'est que
et je ne suis pas certain je ne veux pas
comme ça préjugés parce que la situation
est grave et les politiques lorsqu'on
s'exprime sur ce cette crise inédite
il faut qu'on le fasse avec
responsabilité dont je vais essayer de
le faire les responsables milité en
étant vraiment à la hauteur de la
situation
mais je ne suis pas sûr je ne suis pas
sûr que les réponses qui vont être
apportées correspondent bien sûr au à la
politique qui a été maintenant menée par
emmanuel macron depuis plusieurs mois
pourquoi parce que dans cette crise là
les français nous disent nous voulons
plus de justice plus de justice fiscale
plus de justice fiscale
ce serait d'abord le rétablissement de
l'impôt sur la fortune
est-ce qu emmanuel macron est prêt à le
faire rétablir l'instant écartée pour
l'instant en tout cas ils l'avaient
écarté oui donc c'est pour ça que je
suis sceptique c'est rétablir l'impôt
sur la fortune comme nous le demandons
nous les socialistes n'ont pas pour de
façon idéologique mais tout simplement
parce que nous considérons que l'impôt
il doit être juste et chacun doit
apporter sa contribution en fonction de
ses ressources premièrement est ce qu'il
faut et deuxièmement je termine sur
l'impôt sur la fortune
pas seulement une mesure idéologique
mais surtout rétablir l'impôt sur la
fortune pour financer la transition
écologique parce que aujourd'hui c'est
ça la goutte qui a fait déborder le vase
c'est que la transition écologique elle
ne peut pas être financé par ceux qui
sont déjà en difficulté parce qu'ils ont
que leur véhicule pour se déplacer donc
il faut rétablir l'impôt sur la fortune
c'est 3 milliards d'euros un peu plus de
trois milliards d'euros pour financer la
transition écologique
la deuxième chose ça a été aussi un
élément qui a fait la bascule si je puis
dire qui a créé la situation dans
laquelle on est aujourd'hui c'était le
relèvement de la csg sur les petites
retraites
le gouvernement fait un premier geste
mais il est insuffisant c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui
pour faire court l'augmentation était de
plus de 2000 ans nous demandons que
cette mesure est là jusqu'à 3000 euros
et enfin la troisième mesure que nous
que nous demandons c'est que sur les
petites retraites sur les allocations
familiales sur le rsa la revalorisation
de ce de ses différentes prestations se
fasse sur la base de l'inflation parce
que sinon les chansons relève de
l'argent rien verse de l'argent et
soirée indique c est ce qu il faut
rajouter c'est que ces gens qui perdent
de l'argent subissent la double peine
parce que d'abord elles sont en général
pour l'immense majorité d'entre elles
ces petits retraités ses bénéficiaires
d'allocations familiales rsa etc
ce sont des gens qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté ça c'est la première
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que vous leur servait une
prestation qui quelque part
aujourd'hui ne colle plus au coût de la
vie dans quelles sont doublement
pénalisés donc moi j'attends emmanuel
macron sur ces mesures là et on verra
effectivement s'il a attendu le il a
entendu le cri la colère des français et
quand j'entends je termine vraiment
là-dessus et ans et quand j'entends le
premier ministre dire il faut avoir de
la considération pour les français il
faut les traiter avec respect je
regrette qu'on ne l'ait pas ferran parce
que je rappelle quand même que dans la
campagne des présidentielles et ça il
faut le dire à ceux qui nous écoutent et
moi je le dis à tous ceux qui j'espère
qu'ils sont pas nombreux s'apprête à
mettre un bulletin sur la république en
marche au moment dé des européennes je
rappelle que dans la campagne des
présidentielles emmanuel macron disait
avec moi aucun retraités ne perdra du
pouvoir d'achat aujourd'hui deux
retraités surpoids vous y avait pouvoir
d'achat oui j'ai voté manuel macro
deuxième tour mais si j'avais été le
seul à le faire fait du cna y est je me
serais dit j'ai rien compris
excusez moi de parler un peu
vulgairement je me suis planté sauf
qu'il ya des millions de français qui
l'ont fait pas seulement moi on l'a fait
pourquoi parce que face à nous nous
avions madame le pen et nous ne voulions
pas madame le pen moi j'ai les faits au
2e tour au premier tour j'ai soutenu de
toutes mes forces benoît hamon parce que
je suis socialiste et je resterai
socialiste quoi qu'il arrive chez
soutenu benoît mans et j'ai fait
macro deuxième tour pour battre madame
le pen
et la deuxième chose que je voudrais
rajouter tout simplement c'est que
rappelez vous quand même là le grand
thème de campagne d' emmanuel macron
c'était de dire je vais faire les bonnes
mesures à droite et je vais faire les
bonnes mesures à gauche sauf que je
prends je viens de prendre un certain
nombre d'exemples sur les petites
retraites sur la suppression de l'sf
extase sauf que depuis deux ans
maintenant la politique que nous voulons
mettre en oeuvre c'est une politique
libérale c'est une politique de droite
donc je ne peux plus - soutenir cette
politique localement les les élus ont
essayé également de répondre à cette
crise au niveau la région didier robert
fait des propositions pour le pouvoir
d'achat et notamment la proposition
d'aidé au fret une sorte de continuité
territoriale des biens et des
marchandises dans celle qui pourrait
être éventuellement financés par
l'argent
enfin l'europe est ce que c'est une
bonne mesure pour ça que je vais
reprendre la formule du président du
ceser c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
philippe maillet président du ceser
c'est un expert il dit que c'est une
fausse bonne solution pourquoi parce que
d'abord vous allez financer une partie
une partie dure sur coup final qui est
le fret parce que chacun sait bien que
il y a le fret mais il ya les marches il
ya plein de choses il n'y a pas il ya la
question de l'octroi de mer etc
il ya la tva sur l'octroi de mer vous
prenez qu'une partie premièrement
deuxièmement il propose également perdre
un ou deux autres mères je vais terminer
je répond d'abord à la première question
pour qu'on s'y perd 2 pas donc c'est pas
une bonne idée
la solution de prendre en charge le fret
parce que nous allons financer avec de
l'argent public
nous allons financer avec de l'argent
public une petite partie du coût des
marchandises sans avoir la certitude que
le prix des marchandises mais c'est moi
je vous pose une question sur le dantec
à mon tour nous avons aujourd'hui la
continuité territoriale
c'est financé par la région est ce que
le biais des avions a baissé
non parce que tout simplement il faut
pas se raconter d'histoires tout
simplement parce que les prix non ils
n'ont pas baissé à les interroger les
réunionnais regarder tout au long de
l'année dans les billets d'avion reste
cher et ils n'ont pas baissé pour une
raison très simple qui se comprend d'un
point de vue des opérateurs c'est que à
partir du moment où les billets d'avion
sont financés à partir du moment où les
avions sont pleins
quel intérêt il y a abaissé le prix des
billets d'avion et ça va être la même
chose avec le fret et jeudi un dernier
point sur le fret c'est éminemment
dangereux c'est éminemment dangereux
pourquoi parce que nous ici à la réunion
notre il ya nous avons deux problèmes
qui sont majeurs nous avons la cherté de
la vie mais nous avons aussi la question
du chômage il dans tout ce que nous
faisons nous les politiques dans toutes
les mesures que nous devons prendre que
nous prenons nous devons nous poser une
seule question est ce que ce que nous
faisons est bon pour l'emploi
mais quand vous financez le fret vous
favorisez les importations quelque part
vous encourager par la production locale
donc et je regrette quand même que le
président de région qui est celui qui
est à la tête de la collectivité
stratège à la réunion puisse in fine et
pour sortir d'une crise qu'il a lui-même
provoqué sorte ce genre de solution qui
est vraiment qui n'est pas à la hauteur
de l'enjeu et surtout qui est dangereuse
quelles sont les réponses à la crise des
déchets les jeunes en termes de pouvoir
d'achat ce que vous dites
la question est évidemment centrale ici
à la réunion quelles sont les solutions
que les u16 pourrait porter d'abord j'ai
dit que ce qui est important c'est
aujourd'hui s'attaquer à la cherté de la
vie le l'autorité de la concurrence doit
remettre où il a fait son rapport
moi je pense qu'il faut maintenant
arrêter de tourner en rond
arrêtez avec les deux me solution nous
devons aujourd'hui frappé fort sortir
des sentiers battus à il faut
concrètement je vais y arriver
concrètement jeu est joli tout ça à
l'europe je lis tous à l'europe c'est
pour cela que je suis candidat et quelle
que soit ma place sur la liste c'est une
idée que je vais porter
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on l'a vu
notamment sur les matériaux de
construction mais pas seulement sur les
matériaux de construction
un des éléments de la cherté du coût
final sceller michael conscient pourquoi
parce que pour l'essentiel pour
l'essentiel ils ont importé d'euros ce
qui renchérit les produits
nous devons aujourd'hui obtenir de
l'europe un certain nombre de
dérogations pour des produits qui ne
mettent pas en concurrence mois
contrairement à didier robert qui ne
mettent pas en concurrence la production
locale
nous devons chercher nos marges nos
produits dans le grand bassin régional
dans le grand bassin régional parce que
moi je suis persuadé que l'avenir de là
réunion qu'est ce qui nous en empêche
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
dérogations qu'il faut obtenir de
l'europe c'est ça moi si je suis
candidat sur la liste deux européennes
c'est pour cela parce que je suis
intimement convaincu que l'avenir de la
réunion passe par son ancrage dans le
bassin régional seulement il faut pas
que nous soyons les petits gentil hein
qui prennent tous ces licences ses
possibilités c'est engagement existent
déjà dont et de la coopération régionale
permise même mairie mais rien ne se fait
monsieur le dantec la coopération
régionale les foins terek tout ça je
veux dire que on inaugure des agents
sans intérêt que c'est un fonds
européens pour faire court qui finance
qui encourage la coopération régionale
il n'y a pas de véritable stratégie là
dessus moi si je suis député européen et
avec les gens qui seront élus sur la
liste de glucksmann et du parti
socialiste et de nouvelles donnes
je vais militer je vais me battre pour
qu'on travaille sur ce point là
comment mais je veux le faire pas seule
dans mon petit coin je veux le faire
avec les acteurs économiques également
comment faire pour qu'on obtienne un
certain nombre de dérogations pour
ouvrir ici à la réunion je parle des
matériaux de construction
je ne veux pas qu'on fasse entrer à la
réunion des produits qui vont
concurrencer la production locale
donc ça c'est un premier point pour
faire baisser les prix parce que nous
importons trop d'europe et ça coûte
beaucoup trop cher au final
moi vous savez je je
je suis à la tête d'un organisme de
logement social
il ya deux choses à se dire la sodiac il
ya deux choses qui pèse in fine et sur
le coût de la construction est donc sur
le loyer à des plus modestes parce que
quand je fais du logement je fais du
halal ts donc je fais pour les gens qui
sont les plus modestes ya deux choses
qui peste c'est le coût des matériaux de
construction
et la deuxième chose ce sont les normes
parce que quand pléiade normes plus à un
coup donc voir comment dans une
coopération dans un ancrage territorial
on peut trahir les autres je termine là
dessus nous avons une chance et la
région a été à côté de la plaque pendant
toutes ces années nous avons une chance
exceptionnelle
nous sommes à cinq heures d'avion de
l'inde
l'inde c'est un milliard trois cents
millions d'habitants c'est un taux de
croissance l'année dernière qui était
supérieur à 6,6 pour cent la chine
pareil l'afrique aujourd'hui est en
plein boom et nous ne travaillons pas
avec ces pays là ils n'ont pas besoin de
nous je ne suis pas un doux naïfs
ailleurs l'inde la chine l'afrique
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en afrique l'année
dernière je termine là dessus sur dix
pays qui ont il est plus fort taux de
croissance dans le monde si c'était des
pays africains ils n'ont pas besoin de
nous mais nous nous avons besoin d'eux
donc il faut obtenir un certain nombre
de dérogations
il faut avoir une vraie stratégie avec
l'europe pour que demain nous
construisons notre développement à
partir de notre bassin régional pour que
nos auditeurs comprennent bien la
situation des rup donc les régions
trafic au sein de l'europe aujourd'hui
ne permet pas d'avoir ce genre de
coopération régionale que dont vous
parlez cela c'est l'article dans son car
9 3 qui qui définit cette autonomie est
pas suffisant elle permet un certain
nombre de choses mais il faut également
des dérogations puisque vous savez bien
que tout ça est déjà pour faire court
tout ça est déjà écrit dans un certain
nombre d'accords
les accords de coopération dans les
traités également donc il faut lier à
des choses aujourd'hui qui sont déjà
bordée qui sont déjà écrites mais si on
veut avoir une vraie ambition il faut
deux choses il faut que nous localement
nous localement on est une vraie
stratégie
premièrement et deuxièmement qu'on
puissent assouplir les dispositifs sans
mettre en péril parce que je termine
quand même sur ma démonstration s'est
pas seulement faire entrer favoriser la
production locale s'est également
rappelé une évidence c'est que nous
sommes sur un marché contre 1 800 mille
habitants aujourd'hui neuf cent dix
mille habitants en 2050
seulement avant donc nous sommes sur un
marché contre un il faut forcément
aujourd'hui obtenir pour pouvoir
produire sur des bons coups il faut bien
sûr obtenir des gros volumes de
production mais ça nous devons aussi le
construire avec ces pays là je veux dire
sur un partenariat qui soit
gagnant-gagnant pour nous dans les deux
sens ça veut dire que importer un
certain nombre de choses mais produire
également un certain nombre de choses
ici à la réunion pour le marché
réunionnais mais également pour l'export
dans la zone océan indien
quitte à ne pas respecter les fameuses
normes européennes dont on parle souvent
et qui est son qui peuvent être jugés
comme contraignante mais qui veulent
dire aussi peut-être des protections
terme d'écologie en nombre de conditions
sociales de production dans les pays
voisins
il faut si non nous devons à mon sens un
jeu pose le débat là c'est je pense que
c'est un débat qui va revenir dans la
campagne des européennes
moi je pense qu'il y a deux hommes qu'il
faut absolument respecter la première
norme c'est la norme écologique
je veux dire qu'on ne peut pas elle les
accords de paris il ya eu 195 pays qui
ont ratifié les accords par y céder
françois hollande je suis socialiste
mais je veux dire que sinon je serais en
totale contradiction avec ce qui ce fait
on peut pas avoir ratifié les accords de
paris so landes applaudi les accords
paris et dire maintenant on fait toute
entrée et on se soumet pas aux normes
écologiques non moi je pense que ça
c'est un compte
la deuxième norme à laquelle il faut
absolument souscrire il faut être
vigilant il faut laisser rien passé
c'est bien sûr la norme où les normes
sanitaires
voilà voilà mais c'est vraiment quelque
chose de nouveau qu'il faut construire
moi je crois vraiment en l'ancrage
régional
c'est cela qui va nous permettre à la
fois de créer de l'emploi chez nous et
également de baisser le coût des
marchandises mais je rajoute
j'espère quand même que dans les jours
qui viennent
et là on jugera le président macro
jugera edouard philippe
on jugera tous ceux qui les soutiennent
c'est que sur la question de la cherté
de la vie
moi je souhaite vraiment qu'on prenne
des mesures fortes et qu'on dise à tous
ces opérateurs économiques qui se sont
enrichis pendant des décennies sur le
dos des réunionnais maintenant c'est
terminé
pour en revenir aux élections
européennes votre partie de son derrière
raffael lucson qui a fondé son parti son
mouvement place publique
vous avez adhéré tout de suite voit 100%
cette démarche vous savez un cerveau non
moi j'ai adhéré tout de suite pourquoi
on a évoqué la crise des gilet jaune
on est dans une situation de crise
exceptionnelle
nous avons devant nous deux crises nous
avons la crise écologique on l'a abordé
un peu rapidement quand vous et moi je
ne suis pas expert je ne suis pas savant
mais julie je m'intéresse à ce qui
s'écrit j'écoute les experts qui parle
et tout le monde dit que nous avons
douze années devant nous et dans douze
ans c'est pas ce qu'il en sera ça c'est
la première chose et quand vous regardez
les rapports notamment le rapport du
giec est ce qu'il dit il dit les
premiers qui sont touchés par les la
crise écologique ce sont les îles les
architectes du fait de la montée des
océans ce sont les premiers et vous avez
vu mois de février en février on nous
avait dit qu'on avait battu des records
de chaleur et en mars on nous dit qu'on
a battu les records
oubliez donc chacun voit bien qu'il ya
un problème nous sommes devant une
urgence écologique gluzman la roue
tourne nouvelle donne et pour sa
fondamentalement la deuxième crise c'est
la crise sociale où là on a évoqué tout
à l'heure rapidement la situation
lorsqu'on dit à la réunion il ya 40% je
termine juste la tunisie font permettez
monsieur le dantec
lorsqu'on dit qu'il y à 40% de
réunionnais qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté 40% de réunionnais qui vivent
sous le seuil de rencontrer concrètement
ces trois cent quarante mille personnes
l'insee a sorti une étude cette année
pour nous rappeler qu'ici dans un
territoire français un département
français les 10% les plus riches leur
patrimoine moyen c'est un million
d'euros quand les 10% les plus pauvres
c'est 1200 euros est-ce qu'on va
accepter cela donc on a deux crises
aujourd'hui cependant vu de l'urgence
écologique elle était au pouvoir
bien sûr bien sûr qu'il a été au pouvoir
il a fait un certain nombre de choses ça
n'a pas marché
tout n'a pas été suffisant ce que ça
veut dire que non il faut aller derrière
un rafale et de lui seul pour espérer
avoir des lecteurs
non on ne va pas derrière un fake expand
pour avoir tissé lecteur chez les 10 ou
alors j'ai pas été clair dans mon
explication on va derrière un pack plus
mal parce que nous sommes dans une crise
écologique
nous sommes dans une crise sociale et il
faut se rassembler il faut mettre ces
petits ego derrière soi moi vous savez
quand on m'a proposé d'être sur la liste
j'ai pas appelés en demandant est-ce que
je vais être éligible je vais être 1er
2e 3e etc
c'est pas mon problème mon problème
c'est de porter un message je suis un
élu je connais la situation je reçois
les réunionnais tous les jours je me dis
à l'urgence écologique se rassembler ce
que vous expliquez vous êtes sur la
liste pas sur la liste
non je suis fou était 6e et en fait
c'est la sixième c'est le sixième homme
sur une liste je viens en plus les cours
d'eau vers nantes vous explique ça en
deux mots d'abord je reviens ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure il faut se
rassembler la situation est grave il
faut pas qu'on laisse aux français on va
environ scellier scellier
il est quand même sur de bonnes bases
avec place publique et nouvelle donne
sur mon classement
ce que les camarades les adhérents
socialistes ont voté c'est un classement
chez les socialistes
moi je suis 5e chez les socialistes sur
plus de 100 candidats bien comme
cinquième homme mais sur la liste finale
oui sur la liste que socialiste mais il
faut attendre maintenant le classement
définitif par rapport à nouvelle donne
par rapport à place publique vous
emmèneront 30e place
je ne sais pas monsieur le dantec pour
moi c'est pas le plus important pour que
vous serez fixé dans quelques jours mais
pour moi ce qui est important mais pas
aux positions éligibles
ce qui est important pour moi en jeu
pour d'autres pour moi ce qui est
important c'est de travailler pour le
rassemblement de faire passer un message
auprès de mes camarades qui sont qui
vont être élus pour leur dire que à la
réunion la crise est grave nous avons
une crise sociale nous avons une urgence
sociale nous avons une crise écologique
il faut être à la hauteur et moi
j'espère porter un certain nombre de
mesures de proposition dans cette
campagne les sondages alors on sait ce
que valent les sondages ne sont qu'une
photographie à l'instant t de ce que
ferait les français six élèves
aujourd'hui voici que c'est son oeuvre
au second tour donne votre liste entre 5
et 6% actuellement
ça veut dire ça va pas sûr même d'avoir
un élu à peine 5 % ces cinq élus en tout
5 % des personnes en dessous de 5 % il
ya cinq semaines vous avez dit 5,6 bon
vous pensez bien qu'on va faire campagne
on entre la liste n'est pas connue vous
l'avez dit vous-même le programme n'est
pas totalement détaillé je pense que
c'est une affaire de jours maintenant je
suis persuadé que lorsque la liste sera
connue le programme sera détaillée vous
verrez les choses s'inversent on vous
espérez encore des ralliements
j'espérais que des listes puissent
fusionner vous avez parlé du soutien
vous apportiez à benoist rambaud qui
part seul avec les générations les verts
qui étaient partis ensemble avec amour
présidentielle vont tout seul le pc fait
une liste la france info
ça fait quand même de la dispersion de
voix à gauche et moins qu'on puisse dire
moi c'est pas que j'espère je souhaite
vraiment que l'esprit de responsabilité
l'emportent
on est tous d'accord pour dire qu on est
dans une situation qui exige de chacun
qu'il soit à la hauteur de ce que nous
connaissons et que nous soyons surtout à
la hauteur des attentes des français des
réunionnais et c'est qu'ils nous disent
arrêtez de faire de la politique
politicienne rassemblez vous il n'y a
pas de grande différence entre benoît
hamon et nous y en a même pas entre
jadot et nous il y en a pas donc tous
ces gens là moi j'espère quand même qu
avant le dépôt officiel des listes on
puisse se rassembler parce que qu'est ce
qui va se passer au soir du 26 mai les
commentateurs vous tout le monde vous
allez commenter le match entre le pen et
macro entre le libéral macron parce que
macron c'est une liste libérale stéphane
dijoux que je respecte qui est un
professionnel remarquable qui est un
réunionnais est un garçon intelligent
mais stéphane bijoux audiences sur la
lys qui laetitia mais lorsqu'il sera
mais lorsqu'il sera stéphane bijoux
lorsqu'il sera au parlement européen
qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va défendre
au niveau européen la politique libérale
que macro mais déjà en oeuvre au niveau
national donc je veux dire que à côté de
cela il faut qu'il y ait un choix d'une
social démocratie sociale bien sûr mais
aussi écologique c'est pour ça que moi
je suis vraiment pour un rassemblement à
revenir sur la liste de de la pétanque
on paye actuellement à l'avion vous avez
dit qu'il ya différence entre eux il ya
une cadeau et vous malgré tout sur la
question écologique il ya une nuance de
taille inquiet qu'on va sur la finance
vous avez dit que c'est cette taxe c'est
ce dont devrait aller chercher sur
l'impôt sur la fortune
l'argent pour financer la transition
écologique les verts eux se disent qu'il
faut aussi remettre une sorte de taxe
carbone qu'ils allaient me le faut pour
là dessus vous êtes différent
oui non mais quand je dis qu'il n'ya pas
de différence c'est que nous convergeons
les écologistes benoît hamon nous mêmes
sur un certain nombre de choses c'est
que d'abord me croire mais concrètement
la pole et ça veut dire que vous pensez
qu'il faut pas taxer le diesel il faut
pas taxer niveau de charges non je
termine parce que si je suis pas répondu
à votre question vous me dites est ce
que d'abord il ya une divergence sur
cette question je termine pour nous
quand je dis qu'il ya des convergences
entre nous c'est à dire que jadot amont
nous mêmes glucksmann tout ces gens là
toutes ces personnes là sont d'abord
pour l'europe
nous sommes européens parce que nous
pensons bien que c'est un modèle je veux
dire qui est enviée dans le monde c'est
un modèle je veux dire sociale même si
effectivement l'europe dans sa logique
elles c'est beaucoup trop
fondée elle s'est beaucoup trop incliné
devant le marché mais ça reste quand
même un modèle aujourd'hui qui est
enviée dans le monde
nous sommes pour l'europe également
pourquoi je pense que c'est partagé par
les autres également parce que chacun
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui entre la chine
qui est sur la route les routes de la
soie et trump qui dit america first si
l'europe ne se mobilise pas je veux dire
qu' elle ne comptera plus donc on est
d'accord là dessus et nous sommes
également d'accord sur les deux autres
points nous sommes d'accord également
avec jadot et les autres pour dire que
l'europe
elle doit d'abord être social elle doit
être solidaire elle doit être
fraternelle elle ne peut pas être
l'europe des marchés elle ne peut pas
capituler à chaque fois de plus comment
faire de la très écologique donc c'est
pour ça que je dis que compte tenu de
cela le reste je dirais pas que ce sont
des points de détails je n'irai pas
jusque là mais je dirais que le reste ça
se discute ça se négocie
comment est ce qu'on fait pour que
l'europe soit moins libérale c'est ce
que vous dites faut qu'elles sont plus
sociale on a le sentiment que tout le
côté libérale de l'europe
dans ces traités dans sa constitution
mais que eux est ce qu'il faut comme le
disent peut-être plus la gauche de la
gauche la france insoumise notamment
est-ce qu'il faut changer les traités ou
est-ce qu'il faut finalement faire avec
comme a fait le ps depuis violents
depuis des années en acceptant parfois
de de voter avec la droite au sein du
parlement robert non il ne faut plus
rien accepter du tout hein je veux dire
que nous parti socialiste il faut tirer
les enseignements d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que je soutiens la démarche de levier
fort parce que sur le rassemblement
parce que lui il a eu le courage de
faire ce que personne n'avait fait avant
lui ils vivent là quel est le patron il
a fait l'inventaire des années hollande
donc je veux dire que il faut qu'on tire
les enseignements quand les gens nous
sanctionne nous les socialistes nous
sanctionne pas parce que nous avons été
trop à gauche et nous sentir n'achète
pas parce que nous avons été
insuffisamment à gauche nous n'avons pas
défendu ce pourquoi nous avons fait le
choix d'être parti socialiste pourquoi
nous sommes allés devant les électeurs
donc sur la question des traités moi je
pense qu'il ya deux choses on a un peu
tendance souvent mélangés d'y aller
traiter traité d'organisation de
l'europe et il y a les traités
commerciaux
c'est sur les traités commerciaux je
pense en particulier aux états je pense
que c'est sur les traités commerciaux à
celui d'autres états unis canada
c'est sur les traités commerciaux qu'il
faut être impitoyable
on a parlé tout à l'heure des normes
environnementales sur les traités
commerciaux
nous ne devons plus je termine nous ne
devons plus accepter des des traités qui
le prennent en compte les normes
environnementales les normes sociales et
les normes sanitaires
on parle des relations extérieures de
l'europe qui doivent être plus ou moins
calme et dans le fonctionnement de
l'europe dans le marché interne de
l'europe qui aujourd'hui peut empêcher
de financer des entreprises parce que
on considère que ça serait une aide
d'état et que cela fausserait la
confiance dans une logique libérale est
ce que cette logique libérale a levé sa
remorque
oui nous la remettons en question mais
cette logique libérale à mon sens elle
passe par deux choses c'est que d'abord
les réunionnais qui vont s'exprimer
ils doivent d'abord voter pour ceux qui
aujourd'hui prennent l'engagement de ne
pas s'inscrire dans cette logique
libérale
c'est le cas de glucksmann nous ne
sommes pas les seuls à 1 mais c'est le
cas de glucksmann parti socialiste
nouvelle donne de la liste sur laquelle
je suis ça c'est la première chose c'est
la deuxième chose je pense que on le dit
maintenant depuis des décennies il faut
dans la gouvernance même européenne il
faut rééquilibrer également le leyrolles
en faveur du parlement parce que les
députés je veux dire que les députés
contrairement aux commissaires européens
ils sont choisis par les peuples ils
sont choisis par les citoyens par les
électeurs si les gens font le choix
d'envoyer au parlement européen des gens
qui disent nous on va aller là-bas pour
combat toute démarche libéral pour
remettre le curseur sur le social mais
il faut que quand ils arrivent là bas il
est le pouvoir de le faire également
donc aujourd'hui je pense que il faut
également rééquilibrer les pouvoirs au
sein de l'europe en faveur du parlement
pour que le parlement il puisse proposer
puisse décider si vous souhaitez poser
une question à notre invité philippe
maillet premier secrétaire du parti
socialise minutes qui viennent vous
appelez au 0262 99 2000 vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure la liste renaissance à la
liste de la majorité présidentielle qui
est actuellement en campagne et la
réunion avec stéphane dijoux avec
nathalie
deux listes hier ils ont obtenu le
soutien du président du département
signature et du président du conseil
régional didier robert dit quoi c'est
une belle prise ça vous étonne non ça a
fait rire tout le monde
chacun bien compris moi ce matin j'ai
changé avec à peu près une dizaine de
personnes tout le monde a bien compris
que entre cyrille melchior et didier
robert il ya une course aujourd'hui pour
s'accrocher à la branche république en
marche parce que les républicains sont
pas très en forme et que dans cette
course là il s'agissait de savoir qui
allait marcher plus vite que l'autre
alors est-ce que c'est melchior qui
marchent plus vite parce qu'il a apporté
son soutien avant
ou est-ce que c'est didier robert qui a
prises et qui a fait une prise de parole
hier donc voilà j'ai pas d'autres
commentaires à faire
alors on sent bien que c'est de
l'opportunisme politique vous êtes un
proche du général qui lui soutient la
politique dévoyée par contre qu'elle a
soutenue de manière assez claire jusqu'à
maintenant est-ce qu'il va vous soutenir
vous est ce qu'il va soutenir la liste
europe et coûté vous vous croyez
sérieusement que gilbert annette qui au
parti socialiste depuis 40 ans il va
soutenir une liste on parlait tout à
l'heure de social et cetera qui dit il
faut une europe sociale
mais l'europe sociale que propose madame
l'oiseau que propose stéphane bijoux
c'est une europe sociale écoutez moi
bien où le smic serait 50% du revenu
médian c'est à dire le seuil de pauvreté
816 elle a précisé qu'il s'agissait des
deux astres dans les pays où il n'existe
vous voyez je sais fanette soutenir cela
et vous voyez ce cadre il a soutenu
macro il a soutenu sur un certain nombre
de poids quand emmanuel macron des
doubles les classes dans les quartiers
prioritaires où les zones d'éducation
prioritaire le maire de saint denis qui
a mis au coeur de son projet la haute
qualité éducative
il peut qu'applaudir mais peut pas
applaudir surtout vous voyez
sérieusement gilbert annette aujourd'hui
se retrouver auprès de cyrille melchior
didier robert toutes ces personnes là
qui sont des libéraux des conservateurs
non je ne pense pas mais invité gilbert
annette je pense qu'ils vont répondre à
beaucoup mieux que moi
ou est-ce qu'on est le ps réunionnais
dont vous êtes vous êtes le patro après
cet épisode d gillot ou les élus ou les
partis politiques ont été gardées c'est
bon qu'on puisse dire où son nouveau
livre seront bien sûr le la fédération
socialiste à la réunion c'est un millier
d'adhérents aujourd'hui je vais pas vous
dire que c'est facile mais je profite de
cette occasion pour saluer tous nos
adhérents ce samedi mais ceux de saint
pierre de saint benoît de bras panon de
la plaine des palmistes de sainte marie
saint joseph au sud de saint joseph bien
sûr camarades socialistes à saint joseph
10 mars de 2 des batailles al anon delà
de la gauche avec avec philippe le
breton avec parce que il ya encore une
gauche socialiste rennaise
moi je vous me connaissez je suis pas
quelqu'un qui cherche à me battre contre
les gens qui se disent progressistes ou
de gauche moi je me bats d'abord contre
les libéraux je me bats d'abord contre
ceux qui font croire aux réunionnais que
les solutions sont des solutions de
facilité
je me bats contre ceux qui pratiquent le
client passe comme le président de
région et par la question mais je
reviens sur la fédération socialiste
écoutez la fédération socialiste
aujourd'hui c'est mille adhérents il y
apprit de 400 qui sont venus voter ce
qui fait un taux de participation de 40%
qui est conforme à ce qu'en général les
taux de vote ou de participation lorsque
même dans le passé nous étions plus en
forme sur les européennes je peux vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui moi avec mon
secrétariat fédéral avec audrey bel
hymne qui m'accompagne aujourd'hui avec
notre député de la première
circonscription ericka bareitgs
je travaille nous travaillons le parti
et combattait convalescent mais il est
debout
il ne court pas encore mais il est
debout et j'essaie de faire en sorte
qu'ils soient crédibles qu'ils soient
sérieux qui soit à la hauteur des
attentes de nos concitoyens à propos de
ribery est ce qu il est toujours
question qu'elle prenne son siège de
sénatrice
vous auriez les informations comme quoi
ya du changement là dessus pas quand on
interroge michel dennemont il dit
c'était prévu enfin voilà il ya une date
d'accord donc entre entre le npa et le
parti socialiste pour les dernières
éditions et sur sénatoriales michel
mouret le sénateur qui l'un des rares
soutiens à la réunion et donc aux
liquides lcd ce que c'est toujours qui
doit qui doit là c'est pourtant de
mémoire fin 2020 un de mémoire au moment
où je vous parle j'ai pas de raison de
penser que ça se fera pas voilà il ya un
accord que sénateur dennemont a signé
donc il fait son travail au sénat il
soutient macro audrey bel hymne ne
soutient pas macron elle est la porte
parole de la fédération mais cet accord
je veux dire il est signé et pour moi ya
pas de raison qu'ils ne soient pas mises
en application 2020 on a une question au
standard ce qui nous appellent aux
écoutes
bonjour monsieur réunion un peu cache un
peu direct
oui c est ce que vous n'avez pas honte
est ce que vous n'avez pas honte de ce
que vous avez fait de la ville de saint
denis de la réunion
816 la capitale une capitale de
l'outre-mer capitale de la réunion cette
ville meurt le centre ville est
totalement mort dit que vous battez
contre le libéral à saint denis
tout était fait pour les grandes
surfaces en périphérie car podium beau
le centre-ville n'y est rien du tout
aucune animation au calme et lent raid
un moteur une locomotive blanche et
l'économie de la ville et logement
sociaux des couloirs de bus
ça un problème vous êtes les premiers et
pour lancer fébrile à rendre productif
la donne une dynamique raid il est morte
morte au sens propre du terme
comment on peut pour l'heure cette
dernière chose vous même pas des
prochaines cette année ça fait 30 ans 30
ans que le maire actuel a été élu pour
la première fois sk pas un problème
quand tu entends n'a rien de faire
connaître ce résultat parce que vous
n'avez parlons de revenir encore et
demander la confiance des électeurs
merci des besoins du jeu contre le jeu
complète la question quand je dis vous
redemander le la confiance des électeurs
la position oui je jeu sur la forme je
trouve que james est excessif et si je
puis me permettre un conseil tout ce qui
est excessif est insignifiant moi je
vais vous répondre avec sérénité puisque
ça tombe bien pour me poser cette
question parce que je suis les lieux du
centre-ville
nous sommes conscients nous des
difficultés du centre-ville cher
monsieur
et nous ne sommes pas restés les deux
pieds dans la même chaussure moi je suis
arrivé sur le centre ville il y a trois
ans qu'est ce que j'ai fait depuis trois
ans d'abord c'est sous mon action bien
sûr avec l'accord et la responsabilité
du maire de saint denis gilbert annette
nous avons négocié avec la sodiparc pour
que le stationnement payant soit gratuit
en semaine à partir de 16h et le samedi
dès midi nous avons créé dans l'hyper
centre
une centaine de places un foncier que
nous le roi des familles dionysiennes au
moment même où je vous parle à
l'instruction au service urbanisme de la
ville de saint denis à l'instruction il
y a un permis pour la construction d'un
parking de 250 places qui sera livré en
fin d'année dans la rue à sam avec les
commerçants du centre-ville je ne sais
pas si vous êtes commerçant du
centre-ville mais moi je les vois tous
les jour monsieur parce que mon bureau
il est au 98 rue maréchal leclerc cet
après midi j'y serai d'ailleurs à partir
de 15h je les rencontre les jours nous
avons mis en place un comité de
redynamisation pour le relooking du
centre ville et nous mettons en cher
monsieur 3 millions d'euros dans
la redynamisation du centre ville et dès
le mois prochain à la demande des
commerçants du centre ville vous allez
avoir une oct urnes mensuelle tous les
mois dans le centre-ville et nous
prendre en charge le coût la moitié et
enfin je termine parce que l'opération
la plus importante c'est vrai qu'elles
prennent mais c'est une opération hyper
complexe c'est l'opération quadrilatère
et nous mettons le paquet sur côté de la
terre pour le démarrer pourquoi parce
que quadrilatère aujourd'hui et
l'opération qui va permettre de refaire
partir centre-ville concrètement comment
avec ses 750 places de parking public
puisque les commerçants ils me disent
quoi emily smith nay et le la grande
difficulté c'est qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de plats de places de
stationnement